Carrie is lovely to see you here today
eMCON have you been enjoying it I have
loved it it's been really fun and I've
got to me a lot of people it's also it's
good
of course I'm sure they've all been
asking about Game of Thrones today could
you play the brilliant Shireen Baratheon
on the show and what's been the
highlights of you filming so far and for
me it's getting to work with such
amazing actors like Liam Stephen Curry's
KITT rule them it's been it's been a
rollercoaster we have good days you have
bad days but overall it's been
absolutely amazing and I've learned so
much just by watching the opposite
person act because even just the way
they deal with little things like when
they forget the lines how do they deal
with it if they go wrong how they deal
with it if they think something doesn't
feel natural to the scene how they deal
with it and you know it's little things
like that you learned from such an
amazing set now you mentioned some of
you've even working with their live the
scenes where you're teaching Davos to
read what was it like filming that it's
a lot of fun you know you get mean so
far we've only had two yeah two reading
lessons but they've been a lot of fun
because I get to tell them what to do
yeah I get to tell an adult what to do
and it's fun being in charge
I need hold Melisandre exactly what you
thought of her as well done knew it I
did no I think Sheree was very
intimidated by - auntie she knows that
she is a dangerous woman and I think she
just didn't want to let that show I
think it's the case of I'm scared of you
but I'm not going to show that I'm
scared of you because that's the case of
you've lost you know you should be shown
you should be sure that they're
intimidating you but she is definitely
intimidated by Melisandre but she tends
not to show you that your mum isn't
exactly how should we say it team
Shireen is she but your dad does love
you doesn't her well Tara does Tara's
lovely Steven is he's a brilliant actor
he likes to stink he likes to stay in
character as most of the actors do and
so
and I take up on myself I don't I choose
I take the choice not to you know talk
to him when he's in character because I
don't want to be the one to break that
but when were in the car together going
home and stuff he's really really lovely
and he's he's really nice man as well
and and so is Tara Tara's lovely but we
spend we spend like we'd only just met
on the end of season four we hadn't
actually met before then and it was
really nice because she's such a she's
really a lovely woman
now you mentioned of course season four
there which has been a brilliant season
hasn't it I mean but we've got season
five coming up as well I mean how did it
has it compared you going back and
shooting season five compared to those
previous seasons well Sharon was only
meant to be a one season thing she was
meant to come in just appear and then
just that was it and I guess it's really
lucky how her characters expanded and
because I would never have gotten to
meet the people that I had met if it
hadn't been for her character expansion
and so season four for me was fine I was
like to know if I don't come back for
Season five it's fine I've got to I got
to work with such amazing people and
luckily I got the call from season five
and it was just so overwhelming to be
part of the show for four so far three
years where that was only meant to be
one year so it's yes it's an honor can
you tease for us to season five it's
it's a dark season that's what I'll say
it's it's um a lot of stuff happens is
he's on five I don't get the full
scripts and because of the content of
the show and obviously my age but from
what I have heard by talking to other
people on the show there's a lot there's
a lot and so in season five the Shireen
as well and Shireen yeah as you see a
lot more this season which is good I
think season three you see your season
three tour a little bit sees the fall a
little bit more and then sees a vibe a
little bit more as well so it's together
I really enjoyed filming the scenes as
well of course you've got the greyscale
on your face how I knew that you've got
to get in there really early in the
morning to get that don't have any
what's it like it's tiring because
you know you get onto set and obviously
I've been there a little earlier than
everyone else has and people get into
the make up truck and they sit down and
they complain about how early their how
early they're up and I just look at them
it's like em hello mmm no but the makeup
itself takes it used to take three hours
which was a bit of drag but then season
five we managed to think we got it down
to two hours which was really good so
and because I'm still under 1516 my
hours I have to be careful of how much I
work so it's great some of the actors
find a real relief when they're working
with the child because they know that if
the child can't be on there they won't
be there so I can't work I can't be
physically filming until after 7:00 so
in reality they don't actually have to
get there later actually have to get
there extremely early they get there a
little bit before 7:00 so it's almost
like is there a child on set today and
we have to finish at certain time as
well so they their days are shorter so
everyone's gonna have more scenes of
Shireen please just because I don't have
to work any longer they must all love
you carry on says and of course we saw
you in Castle black
in the very end of the show in season
four didn't we and I'm wondering how
that compared to experience coming the
rest of it and what's it been like
opening up into that world of course as
many more people that you meeting well
before I've only ever filmed with three
people I filmed with Liam Stephen and
Carice and that that was it oh so
getting to explore this other set
especially with all the other people
from the night's Night's Watch and stuff
it was it was absolutely amazing because
going from being in a green room like
the green room with two people to going
in a green room full of ten people who
are joking around they get on really
really well as much as I get on with the
other cast it's nice to be in an
environment where everyone's joking and
you know getting told off is it was so
it was just a lot of fun to film with
film with more people especially yes
because of so many more people
it was a bit less time working because
obviously also many different angles and
stuff so you didn't have to be on set as
long as you could usually if it was only
to carry it's been lovely talking to you
today hope you enjoy the rest of your
time on go with phones were going to
enjoy watching you definitely thank you
you